so as we continue our discussion on
Batman rebirth what we do here is pick
up now with the aftermath of
psycho-pirate seemingly causing Gotham
to go insane and for those of you guys
who were just now joining us in this
series you may have just stumbled across
this video DC rebirth is a line of
comics written by DC designed to
basically take what works before the new
52 and blend it with the new 52 and with
characters like Batman he's kind of a
weird quagmire of course we talked about
this in the in the last video but Batman
didn't really get a reboot per se in the
new 52 instead it was just kind of up in
the air whether or not his continuity
had stayed intact and we were to sort of
left to our own devices you know stories
like hush like nightfall like The
Killing Joke they won considered part of
Batman's continuity in the new 52 unless
they were referenced and so we didn't
really get any solid ground we were
really just kind of walking on quicksand
when it came to his backstory but the
fact remains that as part of DC rebirth
writer Tom King had introduced two new
characters
the first was Gotham and the second was
Gotham girl now in the series up to this
point they had basically saved a plane
that was preparing to crash into a river
and Batman was trying to keep the plane
protected trying to keep the plane from
crashing but ultimately he was
unsuccessful and he was even facing his
own death in the process but because
Gotham and Gotham girl that seemed to
have powers it made them almost
identical to Superman and Supergirl
they were able to save the plane and by
virtue of that save you know however
many hundreds of people now what the
series had done up to this point it is
basically given us a view of Batman in
terms of how he sees Gotham and Gotham
girl and his mine he had done a little
bit of back search you know a little bit
of investigation into their history we
saw that in last video where he had gone
to talk to their parents and it had been
Batman himself who had inspired them we
didn't know exactly how they became
Gotham and Gotham girl but we know that
Hank was in a situation much like you
know Bruce Wayne's parents were by Hank
and his parents were walking out of a
theater they head down a dark alleyway
they were held at gunpoint but Batman
showed up and saved the day after that
Hank you become obsessed with Batman and
his obsession had spread to his sister
Claire and the result was that the two
of them had basically become great
humans you know great people they had
gone on humanitarian missions they had
done as much research as they could with
forensics they had basically become
their own variations of Bruce Wayne then
the result was that after some set
amount
time that wasn't really given to us you
know they had borrowed money from their
parents and then they had riemann gotham
girl with superhuman powers and so what
this does is it picks up again with the
last issue where the villains
psycho-pirate had showed up under the
control of dr. Hugo Strange and had used
his powers to seemingly drive Gotham
insane now to say that psycho pirate has
powers is actually a misnomer now
probably shouldn't have said that psycho
pirate to the best of my knowledge and
this is where you know Tom King's not
absolutely clear here psycho power can
be a bit confusing in the new 52 he was
infected with the virus giving him you
know some measure of psycho I guess you
know psionic mind abilities by Brainiac
but in the pre new 52 continuity he was
just a guy who was really good at
manipulating people's emotions um you
know Tom keen doesn't really give us any
definitive explanation on which
psycho-pirate that we're talking about
you know it could very well be that it
is the you know pre new 52 or it could
be the new 52 it could be one version
wearing the costume of the other we
don't really know all we do know is that
he manipulated the emotions of Gotham
and this is shown to us when Gotham had
gone on a tear and basically killed 27
soldiers now his sister Claire is left
behind and she'd escaped repeating the
same things that she's scared that she's
very scared
and of course this is a byproduct of
psycho Pyrus manipulations once he
latches on to a person once he latches
on to a beam regardless of who that
being is and where they hail from in the
multiverse once he manipulates their
emotions that manipulation stays intact
unless someone with sufficient ability
is able to remove those manipulations
now of course Batman being what he is
there's been different circumstances
where he's been successfully doing it
and where he hasn't been successful in
doing it it really just kind of calls
for what the story needs it to be but
what is it happening is we show up or I
guess be transitioned to to the rooftop
of another building and we find a guy
who's standing on the building and seems
to be in the process of committing
suicide now Gotham shows up behind this
guy and and basically you know it seems
as though he's going to talk him down
but Gotham keeps repeating the same
thing I can fix this we can fix this is
the same thing being said over and over
and over again but the guy says no the
guy says that no this cannot be fixed
that the monster men are coming
and this is this is a weird situation
here because we're going to find at the
end of the story is that not everything
is what it seems when it comes to the
realm of the monster men but the result
is that this man has some kind of a
device on his phone and when he presses
the button to activate it it blows up
the building now this seems I guess is
revealed to us to basically be a
flashback in the mind of Claire and this
tells us exactly what was happening
right before psycho-pirate showed up
with Hugo Strange and manipulated Gotham
and so in yesterday's video when we had
simply just picked up with Gotham and
Gotham girl in a building that was you
know immersed in flame we didn't really
know exactly what was going on this is
we just tells us that but what we do
know is that Claire had been taken back
to the Batcave presumably at the request
of that man where she's being cared for
by both Alfred and Duke Thomas now this
is kind of a funny thing here and I
really liked what Tom King was doing
with this with Duke Thomas and one of
the things that I've kind of missed
spoken about so far in the series is
that du talus was supposed to be a Robin
which is sort of ironic because I
covered this in Batman in my Batman
rebirth video Duke Thomas is not
actually supposed to be a Robin that was
a mistake that I made in the previous
videos
Duke Thomas is a character that's just
being groomed to be someone presumably
taking the place of Batman that seems to
be the common idea here
I don't recall whether or not Batman had
actually stated that in Batman rebirth
I'm pretty sure he did I think you just
simply said that Duke was being groomed
for something else but the overall theme
here is that Batman especially with the
events that had transpired thus far and
the eye on Gotham series you know Bruce
Wayne is coming to the conclusion that
with everything that's happened up to
this point with court of owls Night of
owls with return of Joker in death of
the family Batman in game the Bruce
Wayne's kind of coming to grips with his
own mortality that it seems as though
he's basically losing his grip on Gotham
City itself and the result is that
someone needs to be able to step up and
take his place and even if that's not
the case Bruce Wayne also recognizes
that he's not immortal he's not going to
live forever you know he is going to die
at some point in time then even if Dick
Grayson is a great superhero he still
got Bludhaven to take care of you know
Damian Wayne is forming the Teen Titans
you know Tim Drake is off doing his own
thing basically I remember the bat
family has their own situation to take
care of but Duke doesn't have that Duke
was introduced during Scott Snyder's run
of Batman he is a character who led the
you know the we are rotten teen he's
basically kind of groomed himself to a
degree to be the new Batman
and then bruce wayne's are sort of
taking the next step and giving him the
official training so to speak but what's
interesting about this is that Duga
basically relates to Claire again she
keeps repeating the same thing that
she's scared that she's scared and it's
kind of funny that dude doesn't really
pick up on this but in his mind this is
really just a girl that's experienced a
very traumatic event but what Tom King
also does here is he seems to set up a
possible romance between Claire and Duke
Thomas
basically having Duke Thomas you know
comfort Claire as best you can and then
presumably this may or may not lead to a
relationship the reason why I say that
is because in comics it's usually some
kind of traumatic event that leads to a
relationship between two characters
either that or just they kind of start
out as enemies like you know like Green
Arrow and black Canary did and then they
become you know they end up in a
relationship later on down the line but
it's their trials and tribulations that
strengthen that relationship of course
and again this could just be wishful
thinking because I love the character of
Duke Thomas and do Thomas needs a girl
so I figure what better you know
character to have than a newly turned
superhero it's basically you know add to
the existing bat family as someone that
can fight alongside Duke Thomas and so
what we do is we transition back to
Gotham and you know Gotham is again
continuing this rampage talking about
how he can fix things and it's just sort
of tearing you know doing things apart
but Bruce Wayne shows out that man shows
up and says look everything you've done
at this point you killed 27 soldiers you
know you cannot fix this you know but
what Bruce Wayne also does is he gives
us his official view he gives us an
official exposition on what he thinks
about Gotham this is cool because it's
something that we haven't seen before
we've seen him poking around we've seen
him doing investigating but this is
basically the conclusion that he came to
when he first met Gotham
you know Gotham and Gotham girl had
saved that plane from crashing into the
river and Batman realized that they can
do things that he can't they basically
Gotham City's own Superman he had looked
to them as possibly the next step and
what Tom King seemed to be doing or at
least in my mind anyway as I was reading
this is if Duke Thomas is being groomed
for a replacement for Bruce Wayne then
Bruce Wayne himself looked at Gotham and
Gotham girl as you know kind of attacked
on addition to that in unexpected you
know an unexpected way for him to
basically bolster the continuation of
the bat family they kind of continue the
legacy going forward but the result is
that Batman says that despite the fact
that he looked at both Gotham and Gotham
growth as people that could have saved
Gotham City in
way that he couldn't in the end Gotham
killed 27 people and it basically seems
as though he is officially a villain or
some former fashion a villain that's
that has ulterior motives or simply just
lost his mind became drunk with power
now one thing to point out here is that
Batman does not know about psycho-pirate
and he were human in his mind he simply
just stumbled onto a circumstance where
27 people were killed the word I am
Gotham was written in blood and so
Batman simply went by the evidence that
existed at hand but once he and Gotham
began to get into an argument once they
begin to you know to discuss it I guess
you know debate with one another uh what
isn't happening is of course Gotham
takes off after this joining the
Batmobile and Duke chimes in to Batman
stating that he's found a pattern you
know among these soldiers that were
killed and what he says is that their
dog tags when the numbers are rearranged
when the numbers are you know when the
pattern is discovered the number comes
out to be 24 and what is up happening is
Batman puts two and two together and
realizes that you know this basically
adds up to Task Force X now the way this
ties into Task Force X is actually
really really cool and this is one of
the things that I like about Tom King
because he basically expands on the
clandestine nature of the Suicide Squad
but he's also released also seems to be
leading up to the Justice League vs
Suicide Squad event which would be the
first major crossover of the DC rebirth
line of comics but what he says or what
dude says that after cracking the code
he came to realize that the unit in
particular that was killed was the 24th
unit of a military you know military
group and the 24th letter of the
alphabet is X and so what Batman ends up
doing here is coming to the realization
that X stands for Task Force X which is
the other name that's the official name
for the Suicide Squad and so what he
ends up doing is he basically travels to
where Amanda Waller at least we travel
to where Amanda Waller is located and
she's essentially talking to a military
general now what's really cool about
this is you know Amanda Waller in this
bunker in this military base that
they're at is actually below Gotham City
itself and it's the last place we would
expect to find her to be quite honest we
you know with Amanda Waller
in the new 52 we would have expected to
see her in the field but this is what's
so cool about DC rebirth is that it
gives us the old Amanda Waller that were
used to before the new 52 and so she's
the office worker but she is cold
blooded I like to think of her as the
mob boss of the DC Universe in the sense
that she's a person you know across you
know she knows all the right people
she's like the J Edgar Hoover you know
she's got info on everybody and those
individuals that she wants to stay in
power stay in power and those that she
doesn't want to stay in power do not
stay in power and so while she's talking
to this military general the guy says
that it's impossible for Batman to find
them you know that they are you know
miles below the surface of Gotham City
Batman will never think to look for them
in Gotham City he's got soldiers he's
got huge military-grade doors that
Batman can't penetrate but all of that's
wrong and the reason why is because
Batman is there Batman managed the way
to make his way and now we're not told
how Batman got in there and in truth we
don't really need to be told right now
simply because of the fact that it just
adds to the typical aspect of Batman it
adds to the fact that Batman can go
where he wants when he wants how he
wants and there really isn't anybody
that can stop and plus it just kind of
adds to the mysterious nature you know
of the Caped Crusader as we know him but
you know after he begins talking to
Amanda Waller we learned that from her
perspective
Gotham City has been a very tumultuous
place for quite some time and again this
is basically you know DC grabbing a
combination of the new 52 and the pre
new 52 continuities again with Batman
it's a little finicky here but you know
what we're told is that after you know
the court of owls event the night of
owls
you know the Batman in game the return
to the Joker you know death of the
family all these different events that
take place taking place they did
basically send Gotham into a tailspin of
chaos and what seemed to be destruction
and the result is that for Amanda
Waller's point of view this city
basically needs to be saved the issue
here is that when Hugo Strange and when
psycho-pirate had been assigned to Task
Force X you know as part of Suicide
Squad they hit abandon their mission and
they had basically taken to Gotham City
and that psycho pirate himself had
manipulated the emotions of
of Gotham and sent him down a direction
of insanity Amanda Waller had sent those
military personnel to try to corral
psycho-pirate and he goes strange back
in you know back back to the Suicide
Squad but because they're villains and
they do what they do they ended up
having Gotham killed those soldiers
anyway now it just seems as though what
he ghost Ranger psycho-pirate want to do
is just bring down Gotham City they just
want to instill a whole bunch of
violence you know chaos different things
like that but the result is that Amanda
Waller returns to Batman and essentially
says that he's going to help her bring
down Hugo Strange and cyber-pirate
somewhere because of the fact that one
Batman wants the city saved and to
Amanda Waller will not abide people who
abandon their role in the Suicide Squad
she will have them killed if it comes to
that and so what's also really funny
about this this is one of the things
that I really love about the pre new 52
Amanda Waller is she simply says that
she's only going to help Batman do this
if Batman says please and this is what's
so cool about this because Amanda Waller
is literally telling Batman like you
have to ask me to help you you know not
because formalities but because I just
feel like seeing you beg and that's
what's so cool about this is because you
don't screw with Amanda Waller and it's
just it's super cool you ask any DC fan
you know about Amanda Waller and they'll
tell you by leaps and bounds that number
one it's the Amanda Waller from the
Justice League TV show that was the best
one that justice Lu cartoon show that
was the best version of her character
but to you know the pre new 52 Amanda
Waller in the comics was probably the
best depiction of course she does have
fans for the new 52 and it really kind
of goes back and forth but you know what
we also learned is that where Batman
believed that it was 28 P or I'm sorry
27 people who had been killed Amanda
Waller actually says was 28 and this is
when Batman realizes everything that's
going on or at least realizes you know
there's a little more going on here that
he thought there was and he ends up
traveling back to the home of Hank again
we had talked about that in a last video
when Batman had gone to interview Hanks
parents to find out who he was where he
came from what his background was and
what his motivation was for becoming a
hero and what we find is that when
Gotham had gone through and killed those
27 soldiers that there was actually 28
but one of those soldiers had survived
and had gone back to the home of Gotham
and had basically killed Hanks parents
and so when Hank realized what was going
on he went back to his home as well and
found this soldier in the middle of you
know his parents murder and the result
is that you know Hank is basically
freaking out he's losing his mind
and Batman tries to talk him down Batman
trisys says no you can still turn back
you can still stop this you can still
set things back to normal
but Hank basically throws that man's
words back at him and says no you cannot
fix this you can only make it worse and
instead he kills the soldier cast Batman
aside and then takes off with the
intention of destroying Gotham City now
again we're still you know we're a
couple issues away from the conclusion
of this story so we don't really know
the bigger picture here at the moment we
don't know if there is a much bigger
role that Hugo Strange and psycho-pirate
are playing here we simply don't know if
they just want to destroy things we
don't really know everything that's
happening but what we do know is that
this is going to lead to a pretty
significant battle a pretty significant
conflict with with Gotham and Gotham
girl and Batman is so on and so forth
but if you guys enjoy this series so far
drop a like make sure you guys hit the
sub button to join the Rob core and yeah
I leave a comment let me know you guys
think and I'll catch you all later peace
you
[Music]